today i'm going to share with you the
best ways to know you have the real
extra virgin olive oil now i'm not sure
if you saw my other videos or not on
this topic but near 80
of all the olive oil sold
is actually
fake in other words it's not the high
quality olives picked and immediately
cold pressed it's usually some diluted
olive oil with sometimes canola oil
sometimes you use solvents
preservatives all right the best test to
know you have the real stuff
as a little tickle or a cough in the
back of your throat a slight irritation
because
of a very specific phytonutrient called
allele canthal allele cancel is a super
healthy
anti-inflammatory
antioxidant now it's not going to be a
major irritation you're not going to
start coughing a lot it's just going to
create a little bit of a sensation back
there and so you know you have the real
deal i mean for years i had no idea i
wasn't consuming the real extra virgin
olive oil and i wasn't aware that until
i actually consumed some
real olive oil and you can really
differentiate the difference real extra
virgin olive oil is fruity it's peppery
it's pungent it's bitter it has a slight
grassy taste but it's delicious versus
the fake olive oil which is just bland
doesn't taste like anything now you'd
want to buy extra virgin olive oil in
glass containers not plastic
and the real stuff is not less than ten
dollars it's usually between ten and
forty dollars because it costs more to
make and it's definitely
worth it i mean if you're buying three
liters of extra virgin olive oil for
eighteen dollars
it's not the real stuff and i think um
it would also be worth it to find their
website and see what their story is is
there a story about the type of olive
they use do they talk about the process
do they actually reveal where it's made
and the real extra virgin olive oil is
pressed it's crushed and it has a
harvest date on the bottle now the one
that i use comes from italy and i've
actually been to the farm where they
grow the olives and i observed the
process of making olive oil it's
extremely high quality and i'll put a
link down below if you want to check it
out but there's many different places
you can get the real stuff all right
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next video
hey before you go
if you're benefiting from any of my
content
i would love to hear about your success
story
please share it in the link down below